hour in spokenberg here in Thailand on
the 24th February the Prime Minister got
lost the president of European
commissioner Ursula from The Lion and
the Secretary General of NATO and
stoltenberg have just concluded their
trilateral meeting and will deliver
short remarks after that it is possible
for medium to ask questions the press
conference is in English with
simultaneous translation into Estonian
first prime minister Gaga's the floor is
yours
journalist is my her great pleasure to
see so many of you here today as it is
our Independence Day tyrions Jerusalem
I'm so glad that you accepted my
invitation to join us here on our
Independence Day when we celebrate ours
105th anniversary of of Estonia this
means a lot to me and it also means a
lot to Estonian people so thank you for
being here let me start by sharing a
thought by diacetes the secret to
happiness is freedom and the secret to
Freedom is courage
Estonia had the courage to fight for our
freedom the same applies to our
Ukrainian friends
uh their Fight For Freedom today is a
reminder that freedom is not given and
it needs constant care Freedom also
needs friends and partners
31 years ago when Estonia restored its
independence after the Soviet occupation
we set as our foreign and defense policy
motto we are never alone again
Ursula your presence here today is its
embodiment Estonia is a proud member of
European union and NATO
NATO and the European Union are the
cornerstones of not only our freedom and
security but that of the whole Europe
gray areas however create instability
and lead to lead to war they must be
become the thing in the past that is why
Ukraine's place is in the European Union
and after the end of the war also in
NATO
for estonians the 24th of February has
always been about celebrating Freedom we
know that freedom comes at a price you
need to fight for it
a light presence here in Estonia
contributes every day to the security of
our country and the alliance as a whole
but Estonia takes its own part of the
burden increasingly seriously we have
been significantly boosting our defense
spending it's nearly three percent now
the will of the Estonian people to
defend our country is unwavering the
number of volunteers who wish to
contribute to National Defense has
considerably increased
today ukrainians are showing
unprecedented courage and commitment in
defending their country the Free World
needs to show the same courage and
support to Ukraine until the last
Russian soldier has left Ukraine Ukraine
must win and the aggressor must push
must be pushed back
for this we must also believe in
Ukraine's Victory Ukraine needs enough
weapons and ammunition to win the war
uh that is why I proposed that EU member
states jointly procure ammunition for
Ukraine during the pandemic we were able
to react quickly to jointly procure
vaccines let us act quickly now and send
more ammunition to Ukraine we must keep
in mind that the threat Russia poses is
a long-term one in addition to the
conventional War they are also waging a
hybrid War to create chaos and divide us
all European countries need to invest
more in their own defense and resilience
we cannot be afraid of Russian Terror
tactics if we fall for Russia's threats
we will wake up in much more dangerous
world
Ukraine and Russia's other neighbors are
not afraid so why should those countries
who are further from Ukraine be afraid
the way this war against Ukraine ends
will Define peace for generations to
come for any peace to us there needs to
be accountability Russian crimes against
Ukraine and its people must not go
unfunished and no Russian leader can be
immune from responsibility as team
Europe and team NATO we have shown
significant unity and resolve over the
past year
looking ahead these are keywords we must
take with us courage belief
accountability and leave no room for
fear thank you
thank you the president of the European
commission also from The Lion please
thank you prime minister
special day indeed the day when 105
years ago Estonia declared its
independence
estonia's determination to remain a free
and independent country has been put to
the test time and again
but Independence was finally restored on
the 20th of August 1991.
and I also want to share a thought or
quote of a famous Estonian the former
president Leonard Mary who said
Europe is not geography
Europe is a Unity of principles
and an allegiance to principles
principles shape geography
geography does not shape principles end
of quote and this is a truth that Putin
has never understood
one year on from the start of his brutal
War
Putin has failed to achieve a single one
of his strategic goals
instead of dividing the European Union
he finds US United and determined to
stand by Ukraine for as long as it takes
instead of dominating the global energy
Market
he has seen his main source of Revenue
slashed
instead of wiping Ukraine from the map
he is confronted with a nation more
vigorous than ever
Ukraine has become a testament to The
Bravery of a nation which will never
relent in its quest for freedom
we have seen that in every single day of
the 365 days since the beginning of this
atrocious War
and just as Estonia stands proudly as a
free and independent state Ukraine will
prevail
you can will prevail because ukrainians
will never neither Flinch nor step back
and Ukraine will prevail because Europe
and its partners and allies will stand
firm
but when you're on the fight rages on
and Putin has upped the stakes
he is sending hundreds of thousands of
young Russians as Canon father in the
trenches in Ukraine
what we saw and heard earlier this week
from Moscow
tells us that as the losses mount on the
battlefield
so does the desperation the delusion and
the disinformation
and that shows this train Putin's regime
is under
but it also comes with real and renewed
danger for Ukraine so now is the time to
Double Down
we must keep giving Ukraine the means to
defend itself
until the Russians end this war and
leave Ukraine
and this is why we stand firmly by
Ukraine as determined as ever
to support Ukraine financially
economically and militarily
to increase our own defense capabilities
and to increase the pressure on Russia
and hold it accountable
Russia is increasingly isolated
I think very telling Was the vote
yesterday in the United Nations 141
countries
that voted in favor of the resolution
condemning Russia
Russia is falling backwards towards an
atarchic economy
cut away from the world
our sanctions are eroding sharply its
economic base
slashing any Prospect to modernize it
we will continue to put pressure on
Russia and on those supporting it on the
battlefield
we will continue going after Putin's
cronies
and we will go after those helping
Russia
to circumvent sanctions or replenish its
war arsenal
at the same time we work to ensure
Ukraine's economic and Military
resilience
first with continued financial support
67 billion euros we mobilized so far
second with increased Military Support
we aim to train 30 000 Ukrainian
soldiers in the European Union
Our member states are delivering
military equipment
and we will turn to Joint procurement
to deliver
urgent military supplies for Ukraine
such as 155 millimeter ammunition
equally important is to work with our
defense industry to ramp up the
production of this ammunition and other
equipment needed by Ukrainian forces but
also to replenish our own stocks
and the akaya you rightly so brought
attention to this at the last European
Council and we are taking action
finally
this is not just about winning on the
battlefield
ukrainians are fighting for their right
to choose their own future
and they have already chosen
they have chosen the European Union
they have chosen the unity of principles
as president Leonard Mary said
the Ukrainian soldiers fighting in the
trenches of bahut are defending this
Unity of principles
and in these dark times
the hearts of Ukrainian people are
warmed by the confidence
that Ukraine will join the European
Union One Day
is how principles shape geography
today I am proud to stand here together
with you and Julian's Italian
celebrating estenius estonia's freedom
and Independence
and I'm proud that we stand here
together in support of the Ukrainian
people
and their fight for freedom and
Independence
I am certain that like the people of
Estonia Ukraine too will prevail thank
you
thank you NATO Secretary General in
stoltenberg please
prime minister Carlos the Kaya
congratulations on estonia's
Independence Day and
president from The Lion The usla it's a
honor to be together with both you here
in Thailand today on this very symbolic
day
over a hundred years ago Estonian troops
fought bravely for their freedom and
Independence
Independence was short-lived but
Estonian people never gave up
and with the fall of the Iron Curtain
you regained your freedom and thank you
so much for inviting me to be part of
the celebrations today the Vlog the flag
Rising ceremony and the wreath laying in
ceremony was really moving and it
demonstrates how much you value your
freedom
your history is a strong reminder that
we cannot take our freedom for granted
freedom is not for free we must fight
for it every day
today it is the Ukrainian people who are
bravely fighting for their freedom
and despite a dark year of Despair and
destruction their determination and
courage will no doubt prevail
one year ago President Putin launched
his full-fledged invasion of Ukraine
an illegal war or aggression
in blatant breach of basic International
rules
he wanted to break the will of the
Ukrainian people and he wanted to break
our Unity
President Putin failed Ukraine stands
and NATO and the EU stand with Ukraine
yet Putin has not given up his goals
he wants a different Europe where Russia
can dictate what neighbors do
he is not preparing for peace he is
preparing for more war
so we must give Ukraine what they need
to prevail
our support to Ukraine risks triggering
escalation
but there are no risk-free options and
the biggest risk of all
is if President Putin wins
because the message to him and other
authoritarian leaders would be that they
can use Force to get what they want
that will make the world more dangerous
and us more vulnerable
so supporting Ukraine
is not just morally the right thing to
do to do it is also in our own security
interest
that is why NATO allies are providing
unprecedented support to Ukraine working
hand in hand with the European Union
again Estonia is leading by example
providing more military aid as a share
of GDP than any other country
NATO presence protects the space for
allies to provide this support
since 2014 we have significantly
reinforced our presence and readiness
from the black to the Baltic Sea
including here in Estonia
NATO's multinational battle group in
toppa led by the United Kingdom the
terse aggression
fighters from France and Germany help
protect your skies
and nations from Spain will augment your
air defenses
all this sends a clear message to Moscow
NATO will protect and defend Estonia and
every inch of Allied territory
our article 5 commitment is iron plant
all for one
and one for all
and at our business Summit in July will
take further steps to strengthen our
Collective defense
we also see progress as regards the
historic accession of Finland and Sweden
into our alliance two close neighbors of
Estonia
28 out of 30 allies have already
ratified accession protocols
I had good discussions with president
adirond in Ankara last week
we agreed to restart the talks and to
convene a terrato meeting between
Finland Sweden and turkey at NATO
headquarters in mid-march under model
species
to discuss the implementation of the
agreement made last June and how to
complete the accession process
and it is good that the Hungarian
Parliament will start ratification
process next week
our aim is for both Finland and Sweden
to join us soon as possible
this will strengthen their security it
will strengthen Europe's security and it
will strengthen NATO
thank you once again for our extra
discussions and at least for your strong
commitment to the transatlantic bond for
North American Europe standing together
to protect our freedom thank you
thank you now it's possible for me to
ask questions please do state your name
media Outlet you're representing and to
whom the question is addressed to please
use microphone which with my colleague
will assist on we have first ready there
please yes thank you Tara myberg for
Public Broadcasting questions to all of
you actually
um about China's position paper uh about
Ukraine and it has 12 points I would
like to know do you find it credible
especially as it um as the China
abstained United Nations vote yesterday
about Ukraine and also before the war
started U.S shared intelligent info
about Russia's troops and preparation so
has United States shared any info about
its claim made by Mr blink and that
China is considering giving weapons to
Russia thank you
but yeah so
um indeed the Chinese paper I think you
have to see the principles they shared
it's not a peace plan but principles
that they shared you have to see them
against a specific backdrop
and that is the backdrop that China has
taken Side by signing for example an
unlimited friendship
uh right before the invasion Russia's
invasion in Ukraine started
so we will look at the principles of
course but we will look at them against
the backdrop that China has taken sites
on the question of supplies of military
support from China to Russia we have not
seen any actual delivery of lethal aid
but what we have seen
are signs and indications that China may
be planning and considering to supply a
military aid to Russia and China should
not do that because that will be to
support an illegal war or aggression
breaching international law and and
violating the U.N Charter and China is a
member of the U.N security Council and
they have a particular responsibility to
protect the U.N Charter and this is a
war aggression violating uh exactly that
Charter
um then on the
the proposals uh under and and the
points presented by China
um so first of all
China uh
doesn't have much credibility because uh
they have not been able to condemn uh
the illegal invasion of Ukraine and they
also signed just days before The
Invasion uh an agreement between
President XI and President Putin
on a limitless partnership with Russia
so I think what we see now in Ukraine uh
is that President Putin is not preparing
for war he is preparing for the exact
opposite for more war for more a new
offensives and therefore most likely
this war at some stage will end at the
negotiating table
but if we want a peaceful
solution we need to also realize that
what happens around that negotiating
table is totally dependent on the
strength and the situation on the
battlefield
so meaning that if you want a peaceful
negotiated solution where Ukraine
prevails as a sovereign independent
nation then we need to support Ukraine
military now because that's the only way
to create the conditions where President
Putin realized that he will not do we
know the battlefield he has to sit down
and uh accept Ukraine as the
independence over nation in uh in Europe
so Military Support today is the way to
achieve a peaceful agreement tomorrow
Yes actually I have
to add because
said you and Charter is also something
that China is and should be respecting
and it says the principles of
territorial integrity and also the right
to defend one's country and and
sovereignty so if they are providing
military
aid to uh aggressor then they go against
this U.N Charter and and that is
dangerous to the Peace of the world in
general thank you
we have our next one pradeep please my
name is
I have one question to the president of
the European commission and one question
to the Secretary General of the NATO to
the commission what measures will you
take to prevent the circumvention of the
European sanctions by the third
countries
and to the NATO Secretary General how
NATO will help Moldova to secure its
defense against Russia
so we are in our sanctioned packages we
are increasing the measures to make sure
that there are neither loopholes nor a
circumvention
we have a sanctions Envoy Davido
Sullivan who is traveling to different
third countries to reinforce the message
that any kind of circumvention of
sanctions will have consequences for
example we have included in our
sanctions packages the possibility to
list
persons or entities that are even from
certain countries that are circumventing
the sanctions by exporting goods from or
importing Goods to third countries from
the European Union and then bringing
them to Russia
um so here increasingly we are giving a
very clear message this this will not be
tolerated and this will have
consequences
of course we are concerned when we see
uh uh the challenges they face and
that's a diet consequence of the war in
Ukraine Moldova is a close and highly
valued partner of NATO we have been
working with them for many years we have
agreed now to step up our partnership
and also to help to build uh defense
capacity we have a tailored defense
capacity building
agreement in place
to help to strengthen their different
institutions and to help them to
strengthen their resilience we also
welcome of course efforts by individual
allies also know that the European Union
is doing it a lot to support Moldova
because I think if there's one lesson
that at least we can learn from the war
in Ukraine is the importance of
supporting those countries which are
vulnerable for Russian aggression as
soon as possible and and that also
applies for moldovan that's uh that's
the reason why I need to work a more
closely and provide more support
thank you next one please
from delphames as you all know any
positive signal from these two large
multinational powers can serve as a
boost for morale for troops on the front
lines and an entire nation in suffering
so my question to president for the lion
would be Ukraine would like to begin
accession talks to the EU within this
year can you tell ukrainians what their
government can do to make that dream
happen and Secretary General stoltenberg
um
president zelinski is coming to The
Villages Summit and Ukraine would like
to see a clear pathway to membership
there so what can the ukrainians do to
make that dream happen and I'd like the
prime minister's thoughts on that as
well thank you
yes the
so it's not a rigid time wise but it
depends on the candidate country and it
is amazing to see the determination of
Ukraine
to go through this thorough process but
at utmost speed
and already their step forward to apply
for becoming a candidate country they
had to do a lot and it was impressive to
see how they were delivering while
fighting a war it also shows the
functioning of the administration and
the highly digitized state of the
administration which is impressive
therefore it is of course in the hands
of Ukraine how they perform how they
reform how they improve uh the status of
their country with strong support from
the European Commission because this is
our task uh to advise and to support and
to help as much as possible on that so I
can only say it is impressive to see uh
the the the strong will of Ukraine to
join the European Union uh the
willingness to reform thoroughly their
country and all this while fighting an
aggressor this is outstanding it's in
their hands we will have as a process of
oral presentation of the progress in
Spring to the member states but more
important is the report in fall that
summarizes for all candidate countries
in the accession process their progress
during the year and I am confident that
Ukraine will excel in this report in the
fall that then will be presented to the
member states
I invited the president zielinski to
attend the NATO Summit in vilis in July
I really hope that he can be be there in
person but of course it depends on the
situation because in the mid-sover
full-fledged War invasion of his country
NATO's position on membership for
Ukraine remains unchanged we have stated
several times that Ukraine will become a
member of the alliance at the same time
we all realize that the first step to
ensure that that will happen is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails as a
sovereign in the plantation without the
Sovereign Democratic free Ukraine the
membership will not be an issue at all
so all our Focus all our efforts is now
on ensure that Ukraine prevails that
Putin doesn't win because then there
will be no issue of a membership for
Ukraine
then when this war ends
then of course we need to ensure that
history doesn't repeat itself
because this is there is a pattern of
Russian aggression Georgia in 2008.
in 2014 and then the full-fledged
Invasion uh last year
and we need to make sure that when the
war ends now that Russia is not able to
continue
to chip away at European security and we
need to break this cycle of Russian
aggression
this will be about enabling the
ukrainians to have strong Armed Forces
themselves so they can deter aggression
themselves but it will also be an issue
of creating the framework
and the under and the uh
political framework that that sends a
message to Moscow that that they cannot
continue to attack an independent
Sovereign Democratic neighbor Ukraine
so we need to help Ukraine move forward
on the Euro Atlantic path uh Ukraine is
part of the Euro Atlantic family and the
first step is to ensure that Ukraine
prevails as a Sovereign Nation
to to add to that gray areas are a
source of conflict and War and that's
why NATO has been the peace project we
have to believe in Ukraine and therefore
we also have to give military aid so
that Ukraine can defend themselves and
and then when the war is over then move
on with the open door policy of NATO
thank you next one please marisel run
for German public broadcaster are the
question to the Secretary General you
mentioned talks with turkey how can NATO
act on on Turkey in order to speed up
Sweden's joining process
so first of all this is a priority for
NATO and and for me and I'm confident
that both Finland and soon will become
full members of The Alliance
second I have uh just met with president
and uh and of course we discussed also
how we can make progress on the on the
accession of Finland and Sweden and we
agreed to restart the talks to convene
the meeting in in Brussels at the NATO
headquarters with Finland Sweden and and
turkey
and and we need also to understand that
so far this has been the quickest
accession process in NATO's modern
history
Finland and Sweden applied in May last
year already in June 30 allies also
turkey decided to invite them and we
also all 30 allies agreed including
turkey on the accession protocols and
all Factory allies have signed these
accession protocols then
28 out of the third allies so this
ratified in the National parliaments the
Hungarian Parliament has made declare
that they will start the accession
process of the discussions and the
decisions last next week and then
on on Finland and Sweden
I cannot guarantee you any specific date
but on Finland turkey has made it clear
that they don't see any problems with
ratification
with Sweden there are some issues Still
Remains I have Medicaid at both Finland
and Sweden have lived up to their
commitments they
signed up to at the NATO Summit last
year so I think the time has come to
ratify both of them now
but of course turkey has no the position
and then we have this trilateral
mechanism to address how to how to
ensure that that the accession process
continues to move forward and and the
most important thing is not whether
Finland Sweden joins exactly at the same
time the most important thing is that
they join as soon as possible you can
briefly add one more thing and that is
that we need to also understand that
Finland and Sweden are the two different
case now they're much more secure now
than before they applied because as part
of the accession process they have now
been integrated more and more into NATO
civilian and Military structures
defense planning capability targets we
exercise more together NATO's increases
presence different allies are also
provided bilateral security assurances
so it's absolutely inconceivable that
Finland or Sweden will be faced with any
military threats from Russia without
NATO reacting so we are making a lot of
progress we have come a long way already
and I'm confident that also Finance this
process
so and time for final question please
James Bays from Al Jazeera Secretary
General I've already asked you this once
this week but please can you tell us
what evidence you have that China is
giving is thinking of giving weapons to
Russia and to all three of you I know
this is the final question so very
quickly and directly you're here for
estonia's Independence but what message
directly to President Putin do you want
to send today about Ukraine's
Independence
well
um we are monitoring closely what China
is doing uh and we have seen signs that
they may be considering and planning to
send a little late to Russia this will
be a very big mistake this is very
serious and that's what that's also why
the United States and other allies have
conveyed so clearly that this should not
happen then briefly on the message to
Moscow the message Moscow is that
President Putin started this War
President Putin can end this war today
by redoing drawing his forces if he
doesn't do that we will stand by Ukraine
for as long as it takes and allies have
provided unprecedented level of Military
Support to Ukraine because this is about
Ukraine it will be a tragedy if
President Putin wins for ukrainians but
will be dangerous for all of us and
therefore this is in our own security
interest to ensure that Ukraine prevails
territorial Integrity but also for
Universal values and these are the
values of
peace
respect for the international law
respect for the U.N Charter and
therefore Ukraine is not only fighting
for its independence but also for all of
us
and we will stand by Ukraine for as long
as it takes we have shown resilience
unity and determination during the last
12 months and President Putin can bet on
the fact that this will be doubled down
in resolve unity and determination to
stand by Ukraine
yes
we are united as shown and we are united
behind Ukraine and Russia can't win this
war so sooner Russia realizes that this
aggression was a mistake the better to
everybody thank you
so thank you everyone this concludes the
press conference thank you for attending
thank you for following online have a
great afternoon
thank you